hello everyone and welcome to today's
broadcast the Washington State
Department of Health's prescription
monitoring program ensuring safe
prescribing it is presented by Gary
Garrity the operations manager for the
prescription monitoring program at the
Washington State Department of Health I
am Judy or elaborate and I'll be your
moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by laberd's lab
routes is the leading scientific social
networking website and producer of
educational virtual events and webinars
before we begin I'd like to remind
everyone this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
anytime you want during the presentation
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
and type your questions into the drop
down box it appears on the screen our
speaker will respond to your questions
via email if you have any trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation please click
on the ask a question box to let us know
you're having a problem this
presentation is educational and thus
offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming
Garry Garrity I will now turn the
presentation over to him
thank you very much hello my name is
Gary Garrity I'm the operations manager
for the prescription monitoring program
at the Washington State Department of
Health we also call the prescription
monitoring program prescription review
kind of our brand name I'm going to talk
to you today a little bit about where
the prescription monitoring program fits
in to ensure safe prescribing I think
part of that really focuses on the
beginnings of that story really focuses
on the prescription drug abuse epidemic
and our current status there this first
slide shows that we've had a little bit
of a little bit of moderate success
bringing prescribing rates down since
about 2008 both in Washington and
nationally reducing opioid prescriptions
is is part and parcel of ensuring safe
prescribing or safe prescribing is is
measured a little bit by bringing this
prescribing rates down which we're quite
elevated here we're looking at overdose
death rates by drug type for Washington
State years 2000 through 2017 and we've
broken this down with between all drugs
with the darker bar at the top all
opioids with the orange line just under
that and then we can see some of that
some of that effect that we've been
having on the prescription drug abuse
epidemic in that teal colored bar where
our prescription opioid overdose death
rate has really been falling since after
about 2010 however that's also somewhat
counter balanced by an increase in
overdose death attributable to heroin
which is the next line down the yellow
and then we started also tracking
overdose death rate by synthetic opioids
at the red bar and very concerned about
the upswing that we've seen since 2015
in synthetic opioid overdose deaths
additionally we can look at our
hospitalization overdose rate and again
broken down by drug types top bar in the
orange for all opioids the the middle
bar in blue for non heroin opioids and
the bottom four for heroin where again
we see an upswing since about 2010 and
some fall-off with non heroin opioids
since since about 2010 also we often
talk about hospitalizations and overdose
rates rates of death when we're talking
about when we're talking about opioids
in the opioid epidemic
however these aren't the only costs to
our public health system right here we
can see that those deaths are really
just kind of at the peak of the pyramid
and there's a there's a whole lot more
depth to the cost of this epidemic
across our public health system when we
look at overdose hospitalizations were
quite a few more hospitalizations as
there were compared to deaths for this
year this data is from 2014
we had 695 deaths we had over 1,500
opioid overdose hospitalizations and
that trickles down again into opioid
substance abuse treatment admissions
where we had over 13,000 in our state
and then again another measure persons
persons 12 years or older who use
prescription opioids non-medically over
250,000 non-medical users of opioids so
this really has deeper impacts far more
far more reaching impacts than than what
we often concentrate on which is death
or maybe even hospitalization rate
also an epidemic that affects our most
vulnerable we see this in the rate of
Naas or neonatal abstinence syndrome
these are babies born already suffering
the effects of opioid withdraw from the
from the Ocoee opioid use of their of
their mothers so we can see that the
rate of neonatal abstinence syndrome has
been on the rise since as far back as
this tracks with 727 reported in 2016
and even with all of these measures and
all of this focus on the epidemic it's
hard to believe that still one in four
teens believe there's little or no risk
in using prescription pain relievers
without a prescription
so now I want to provide you a little
bit of information about the
prescription monitoring program and its
utility the Department of Health in
Washington developed the prescription
monitoring program but really with an
overarching goal of preventing
prescription drug overdose
goals that the department had at the
time this was developed was to give
practitioners an additional tool that
provided more information for making
patient care decisions and provide that
data which can help providers recognize
patterns of misuse and addiction
ensuring that they were able to take
advantage of Esper opportunities for
those of you who aren't aware s Bert is
a Samsa tool and it is screening brief
intervention and referral treatment
SAMSHA of course has got training
guidelines on their website for expert
definitely definitely useful the
department also want to make sure that
those in need of scheduled prescription
drugs were able to receive them create a
tool create a useful tool that didn't
create additional barriers to patients
who had legitimate need data from this
program can be used to educate the
population on dangers of misusing
prescription drugs and all of this
combined can curb the illicit use of
prescription drugs now the way the
system works dispensers mainly
pharmacies in our state are required
under statute to report their dispensing
of controlled substances into the state
PMP which is a repository of that
information that information is then
made available to pharmacists and
prescribers for patient query access
information is also made available to
law enforcement licensing entities who
can access the system for bona fide
investigations involving a specific
individual our rates for registration
right now pharmacists are around 36% and
that's really one of the highest rates
in our state all of our prescribers
among all of our Washington licensed
prescribers
registration rate is about 20% for
direct direct porthole query access
we do have some cases where some
dispensers are not required to report
data and I'll run through these real
quickly licensed wholesalers
distributors and manufacturers are not
required to report the system anything
that's prescribed for less than 24 hours
or is directly administered by a
provider is not required to be reported
to the system prescriptions provided to
patients receiving inpatient care at
hospitals are not required pharmacies
operated by the Department of
Corrections giving care to incarcerated
individuals except what in the case
where an offender might be released with
a dispensing intended for greater than
24 hours of use of course federally
operated facilities don't have to follow
along with state laws however Veterans
Affairs and IHS have been reporting to
the Washington PMP voluntarily since
2015 so an opioid treatment programs are
prohibited from reporting their
dispensing under 42 CFR
so a little bit of history legislation
for the program was passed first in 2007
RCW 70 point 2 to 5 in Washington in
2010 and October federal funding was
obtained for implementation 2011 in July
rules were adopted and do H contracted
with an application service provider for
data collection and reporting
then in October an additional federal
award was obtained to finalize
implementation and data collection began
our pharmacies started inputting data to
the system that following January in
2012 query access providers was opened
on the live system and in 2013 there was
finally some sustainable funds in House
bill 1565 which provided ongoing funding
through the Medicaid fraud penalty
account care in Washington and there was
also a proviso with that funding for
integration with Eddy that's the
emergency department information
exchange here in Washington
so access to this information has grown
in some ways our original legislation
provider PMP access for prescribers and
defenses and dispensers for patient care
licensing boards for investigations
individuals regarding for regarding
prescriptions dispensed to them to Eddie
regarding that proviso for integration P
of PMP information into the emergency
department information exchange reports
received in the emergency department
access for of course Department of
Health and the vendor in regards program
operation law enforcement prosecutors
for bona fide investigations regarding a
specific individual also for medical
examiner and coroner for determining
cause of death for the Health Care
authority for their Medicaid operations
and for Ellen I labor and industries
here in Washington for workers comp
claims as well as Department of
Corrections for information on their on
their offenders or incarcerated
individuals we also had access to be
able to provide de-identified
information to researchers and educators
so over the years different legislation
is added additional access to PMP
information in 2015
Senate bill 57 20 provided that staff of
a medical testing lab could access the
system for verify for verifying
prescription drug use in accordance with
urinalysis testing House bill 27 30 and
2016 provided access for healthcare
facilities and clinics when using a
certified EHR connection to the state's
health information exchange also
provided access for legend drug
prescribers at this point no longer was
it lemon no longer was access limited to
only those who held a DEA license for
prescribing controlled substances but
this access as any prescriber in the
state of Washington can access the
system to follow up on their patient
care and pull down a PMP history report
for their patients delegate access for
do H licensed pharmacy staff was also
added under this legislation in 2017 in
gross substitute House bill 1427 added
access additional access for the
emergency department information
exchange to be able to provide overdose
notifications to recent prescribers
found on the PMP also added access for
the Washington State Hospital
Association quality improvement program
for healthcare facilities and provider
groups of five or more that they may be
able to obtain a PMP report data report
they can use for quality and improvement
and interventions within their
facilities I also provided access for
federal and tribal health care
facilities using their EHR to connect to
the Washington state hie mirroring what
had been done in House bill 27:30
just a little bit of a hole a little bit
of a gap was left they're not calling
out access for federal and tribal health
care facilities
so it's important to note that House
bill 27:30 provided additional access
for health care facilities when
connecting through their using their
electronic health record systems to
connect to the hie this allows easier
integrations at the healthcare facility
level it also reduces the onus reduces
the need for providers to register for
an individual PMP account that
registration and access through the
portal and has been it is somewhat of an
onerous process but when the facility
the result of this legislation is that
the facility then has the authority to
create the transaction the query to the
PMP and import information directly to
the EHR system where it can be presented
to the provider directly in their
workflow without them having to access a
separate portal of any sort so keeping
them in their workflow when they're
already looking at medications and
already within the flow to make the
decisions that need to be made about
prescribing
so a little bit of information about
what we see with PMP use and its impact
and we can start a little start
discussing a little bit on the level of
what kind of registration what's the
level of registration amongst our per
our prescribers our providers in the
state first off we've got the numbers on
the slideshow we've got a just over
4,500 accounts for pharmacists active
accounts for pharmacy delegates
prescribers at just over 9,000 accounts
and prescriber delegates at just about
4,500 accounts in Washington we've got a
total number of DEA registrants these
are providers who hold active DEA
credentials and can actively prescribe
controlled substances at almost 44,000
when this number was taken at the end of
September when we compare that when we
when we do math between that number and
the number of prescriber accounts that
we have on the PMP we see that only
about 21% of our state prescribers are
active state prescribers have an active
PMP account where they can actually go
and look at the controlled substance
history for the patients whom they're
considering to write a controlled
substance for when we look at this
across a slightly different measure and
that is the total number of do H
licensed personnel who have the ability
to prescribe in Washington we again can
see that we have just a just about 15%
of our licensed healthcare providers who
would who would have the ability to
prescribe have got active PMP
credentials again pharmacists do pretty
well and have about a 36 percent
registration rate on the PMP
in order to ease access provider to for
providers and pharmacists we allow for
delegate use this means that provider or
pharmacists can delegate the authority
to pull PMP reports for patients to one
of their ancillary staff in the pharmacy
that might be a pharmacy technician or
assistant in a medical setting that
might be that might be a nurse it might
be a medical assistant might be a
phlebotomist on the PMP system we've got
nearly 7,000 delegate accounts that are
active and ready to be selected by
prescribers so they can delegate that
access to their ancillary staff
so knowing that the PMP has been
registration and access to the PMP
through a separate portal has been a
little bit onerous we've engaged in a in
a ease-of-use project looking at the PMP
portal and ways that we might improve
access to it one of the first things we
did is we identified and I and defined
some unintentional issues cause at the
healthcare facility level with some
suggestions for intervention so these
are things like health care facilities
not providing access to individual
private email accounts these email
account private email can be used for
the adaptive antek adaptive
authentication challenge that happens
through our security gateway also known
as secure access Washington or saw if a
provider can't receive can't access an
email sent by saw that has a token for
them to then gain access to the system
they are essentially locked out what we
found in some facilities this was this
was a little a step further than they
had looked into providing access that
many times health care providers were
provided access to solve for sign-in but
then when it came to the indication
process that had to happen they needed
access to maybe their private email
accounts which were restricted at the
facility level so our document that we
presented here which is available at the
website WTHI gov slash PMP ease-of-use
draws out really highlights some of
these unintended issues that were
blocking into individual providers from
taking part and being able to access the
PMP fully from their from their
workplace we also improved the track for
registration for login and access to
information from the web
we define this into a a single source a
single track for accessing these
utilities from the PMP webpage that's W
do heo slash PMP and from that from now
from that page you have access for login
for registration for all the information
that you need for PMP and it is really
kind of our one-stop shop for for any
any access to or any information that
you need regarding the PMP we also added
an option for adaptive authenticate
adaptive authentication challenge via
text actually this was our partner saw
again our security gateway secure access
Washington added the text option for
adaptive authentication which really
helped for providers that were in maybe
larger facilities where they didn't have
a good cellular signal for receiving
email or phone call for that adaptive
authentication challenge which was used
to authenticate them and allow them
access to the PMP now that challenge
could be sent through text message they
could better receive it respond reply to
it and gain access to the PMP our
partner secure access Washington also
upgraded their user interface this is a
many of these upgrades were very nuanced
they seemed like very minor very small
upgrades but they had a really big
effect on the success of our users
registering for the PMP something as
simple as breaking a string field down
for name into two blocks for one for
first name one for last name made it
much easier for the system to
authenticate our users and ensure that
they had a successful process that
registering for access to the PMP
here at the Department of Health we've
increased our staffing for the do HP MP
helpdesk we've had a number of new staff
come on board and this is really in line
with the the new legislation under how
House bill 14:27 and the mandates that
are coming out over the next couple of
months and what we expect to see in
increases in registration rates we
wanted to make sure that we were staffed
up and ready to handle the influx of new
providers registering we've also
increased hours at our PMP help desk for
this block of time for this period where
we've got these new mandates coming on
board and we know that there's going to
be increased provider registration we've
increased hours from 6 a.m. to 6 p.m.
currently this data is really about how
frequently the PMP is being used what
we've got here is the gray bars are
showing us the level of controlled
substance prescribing in Washington
which has stayed fairly steady right
around 12 million prescriptions a year
it's completely under that we've seen
some moderate fall-off in the past in
the past couple of years now we might
see a little greater fall-off if we were
to adjust for tramadol which wasn't
scheduled until 2014 so that adds almost
another 3/4 million prescriptions a year
to our to our number here if we were to
adjust that out for the years after 2014
we'd see a little a little greater fall
the peel bars the tri-colored teal bars
are showing our rates of access the PMPA
the number of queries that are created
created or facilitated by the PMP the
lower portion of that the orange and
darker colors are showing query access
directly through our portal and it goes
from almost immeasurable in our first
full year 2012 to to being more
significant through 2017 and 2018 but
what's really important is that upper
part of the bar that lighter teal color
that's showing the number of queries for
facilitated via our automated exchange
over the state health information
exchange
that's automated queries responding
right back and being integrated into
electronic health care record systems
so this quote was really an early
indicator of the importance of that
integration and automation right this
quote came from an eddy user a clinician
in the emergency department when we
first adopted an integrated model with
the Eddy system just as creating a PMP
was game changer pushing that
information without provider bias
without burdensome hurdles now pretty
much mandates providers be aware of
these patient's special needs and risks
now that automation this is what it
looks like to be integrated with a with
a system like Eddie or with an
electronic health care record system
what happens at the hospital level the
hospital uses its connection to the
state health information exchange to
submit a query from the electronic
healthcare records system to the PMP one
health port state health information
exchange recognizes that as query for
the PMP rather than the other data
systems that it services and passes it
on the PMP is able to respond to the
query with information for the
particular patient and pass that back
through the state health information
exchange back to the hospital where it's
populated into the EHR record
so however this isn't just a one-to-one
transaction this isn't a health record
system in EHR system getting access to
only PMP data it really looks a little
more like this where with only one
connection between the hospital the
pharmacy or the provider office to the
state health information exchange they
have access to five different data sets
of the Department of Health as well as
labor of industries for labeling labor
and industry reporting as well as
connection to the Health Authority for
access to the clinical data repository
so it really reduces the overhead of the
end user the hospital the provider
clinic or the pharmacy and having to
facilitate only one connection where
they would have had to maintain seven
you know as many as seven different
connections to separate programs
you
so when Washington be able to Washington
PNP users be able to access information
PMP data from other states
well it's something that we've got our
eye on it's something that we're moving
towards what we have is a situation
Washington is laws and rules that allow
for Interstate data sharing we have
access to we allow access for Washington
PMP users and for users in other states
to access the Washington PMP and pull
reports directly from our PMP systems
we've piloted Washington data piloted
integrating Washington PMP data into the
Eddy system in Oregon so this is a
interstate a model of Interstate data
sharing via the emergency department
information exchange directly from the
Washington system into five pilot
programs within Oregon in the Portland
area being able to ingest that PMP data
for people presenting with with
Washington address okay currently there
are two national data sharing hubs this
is really getting into what are what are
our next steps what's coming down the
pike with the ability for Washington
users to be able to log on to one system
and pull reports from many different
states there are two national data
sharing hubs Washington has executed an
MoU an agreement for and is moving
towards implementing connectivity with
the RX check hub which is growing in
leaps and bounds we expect shortly to be
able to transact data with a number of
different states sadly this this doesn't
right now doesn't include our most
important neighboring states Idaho and
Oregon who are on another data sharing
hub Washington is in a place right now
where the MOU for connection to that hub
hasn't been okayed by our
our Department of Health legal and at
this time we don't have an ETA for for
development of that connection we
continue to work on this MOU and the
language that's at odds and we hope to
be able to facilitate a connection and
interstate that that is hearing across
the second hub as well
with all of that what should providers
be taken away from all of this
number one keep an eye on what the data
is that you're getting data is important
sometimes patient history on the PMP
isn't always accurate there are things
that can be done to improve it got to
remember that the record Genesis really
happens back at the provider office when
when the provider is writing a
prescription
this is this may be the sole opportunity
to interface with the patient and check
an available form of ID for the needle
legal format of the name and you have to
one has to remember that the patient
many times does not present at the
pharmacy and therefore there'd be no
opportunity to check that sort of
identification at the pharmacy if the
pharmacy receives good information from
the provider good data from the provider
along with the prescription this is the
information that the pharmacy is going
to input the PM into the PMP and
ultimately the information that the
provider is going to have access to when
they pull down a PMP report on their
patients in instances where providers
receive inaccurate or incomplete data
from the PMP we do have a process for
reporting that back to the PMP where we
can get it where it's documented where
we can follow up on it and ensure that
corrections are made so we can improve
the data that's available to providers
that process is available from our
website from our website
www.gov.uk/transformation
once providers have taken a look at the
data on the PMP
what does it what should the effect be
on their prescribing well that's up to
the providers interpretation but the
information that's out there the
guidelines for prescribing laid out by
the agency medical directors group says
that safe and effective prescribing
really is all about providing the lowest
effective dose for the shortest
therapeutic duration we also want to
remember that patients need to be
prepared to take the the quickest and
most responsible route for disposal
these medications when left sitting
around in the medicine cabinet may be
enticing to somebody who might want to
use the substance illicitly it also
creates a danger for small children
getting into medicine and easily OD'ing
on these kind of medications we also
want to be able to inform patients about
the need for safe storage so these
medications can't be inappropriately
accessed
you
so the PMP should help providers check
for instances of misuse or multiple
prescribers should help check for drug
interactions especially the instances
where opioids are prescribed along with
benzodiazepines this is a you know kind
of a one-two whammy for patients and and
those sort of interactions need to be
really really considered and information
needs to be provided to the patients
that they that there's a a large
potential danger there can use the
reports for compliance with treatment
contracts if you're a provider providing
treat
providing care under a treatment
contract PMP reports of course help you
keep an eye on what your patients are
doing with regard to controlled
substances it allows providers check
history of transactions linked with
their own DEA number as a provider you
can access the system and you can look
up the history associated with your DEA
number to see if you to see if there are
any errant prescriptions or any
prescriptions there if you know
certainly there have been instances
where prescription pad has been stolen
and there's a number of fraudulent
prescriptions out there so additionally
for providers keep in mind that checking
the PMP is made easiest when you use our
power of delegation if your access is
through the direct query portal if you
have to access the portal the web portal
to do your queries delegate to your
ancillary staff if they're licensed by
the Department of Health they can
register an account and you as a
prescriber can select them for delegate
access they can then pull those reports
on your behalf so that you don't have to
certainly make sure that you train your
staff so that they know how to use the
PMP use a champion in the staff somebody
who maybe pulls these reports on a
regular basis can train other staff as
they're coming on and help them through
the registration process
certainly provide prescribers and
ancillary staff register for the PMP in
exactly the same way so that PMP
champion is going to be able to help
anybody in the office anybody in the
group register for a PMP account make
sure you retain documentation by placing
a copy in the patient file or in or
ingesting into your EHR system integrate
your EHR systems directly accessing
query the PMP automation is key when we
automate this connection the provider
then has the then the information
becomes pushed in front of the provider
rather than provider having to go
through extra steps to pull the
information from the system and when
it's pushed in front of the provider
within their workflow it almost it
almost guarantees the provider is going
to have access to it is going to view it
and is going to have to consider it when
considering to prescribe controlled
substances now when the PMP report
provides information back to the
provider that raises some alarm bells
what happens many times we get calls at
the department where providers are are
put off they're frustrated with the
patient what we say is don't fire the
patient the patient is still in need of
medical care one way or the other this
is a great opportunity to talk with the
patient to coordinate care with the
other providers listed on the report
consider using a patient treatment
agreement whether that's yourself as a
provider being the primary care provider
for the patient or if you reach out and
coordinate with a primary care provider
to suggest that they enter into a
treatment agreement with the patient
verify the prescriptions listed match
your records if you've been prescribing
to the patient go through those make
sure that they are all accurate if
they're not accurate report it back to
the PMP program where we can follow up
and ensure the corrections to the data
on the system refer your patient to
treatment or other specialty care
specialty care is needed or as warranted
and educate patients take the time to
educate them on the dangers and risks of
overdose with these medications
so a few resources that we have
available here in Washington
number one the Washington C medical
directors group the AMD G first
published guidelines back in 2007
they've been updated a few times since
with the most recent update coming out
in 2015 the AMD G really lays out
guidelines for prescribing opioids for
pain in Washington uw-w tella pain it's
a wonderful resource
it's a teleconference where pain
specialists at the U dub participate
every Wednesday from 12:00 to 1:30 and
what they do is they take those
difficult cases that providers might
have consider them and provide feedback
on proper care for the patients a very
quick resource is take back your meds
org this provides a list to provides a
geographical and for interface a map
with all of the available areas all of
the available locations where patients
can take their medications for safe
disposal
stop overdose org which is put up by the
a dia
alcohol and drug abuse Institute at the
U dub and provides a lot of information
regarding overdose education a locks own
anything you might need access to an
information for someone that you're
concerned about using or misusing opioid
medications now I've got a few slides go
through to show you what the
registration process is like and what
it's really like to pull a report on the
PMP so registration you of course we
have a how to register for access video
available from YouTube this is all all
this information is available from our
website at www.uvu.edu/library
and quicker for providers or their
delegates access the system and pull
patient reports right here is our
one-stop-shop for registering for and
getting access to the PMP to pull those
patient query reports available at WWE
what gov / PMP and right at the top
we've got buttons for provider login on
down the page or to the right there
there is a button for information on how
to register first step in registration
is setting up a saw account saw of
course has access or has a Help button
with the saw interface right here for
registering your saw account once you've
registered your saw account you'll
request the PMP service from a menu list
within saw
what you'll need to register you'll
really need about 10 minutes or so you
know it's not just signing up for a
gmail account there's a bit more
security with it Saul will go through a
security authentication process with you
it will take more than two or three
minutes okay you'll need a computer with
internet access you'll need an active
Washington do H issued healthcare
credential and if at all possible have
your driver's license in your hand right
we want to make sure that you're using
legal format of your name and a
registered mailing address you'll need
one or two active email addresses that
only you have access to these need to be
confidential email addresses and these
will be used by the saw system for
authentication process it'll send you at
times when it needs to challenge to
verify or authenticate it'll son send an
email that you'll need to access and
retrieve a numeric token from you'll
also need one or two phone numbers for
this those phone numbers need to be ones
that you can answer directly like a cell
phone
certainly not one that rings in the
front office it would have to be
transferred something like that doesn't
work for the authentication process
you'll need the service code for PMP
this is actually through our ease of use
process no longer necessary you can pick
the PMP service for provider access from
a menu list within saw you'll need your
DEA number if that applies and also your
full social security number so pulling a
patient query again we have videos on
this process it's fairly simple once
you're on the PMP system this is the
view that you have you'll go to query
and recipient query you'll have to check
off the attestation of where you're
allowed access to the interface for
inputting the patient's last name first
name date of birth there's a few options
within the query system that you can
choose to broaden your search based on
date of birth or first name begins with
and last name sounds like there's also
an option on the patient query system
for you to pull queries for more than
patient one one patient at a time when
that returns you'll get a pick list of
different identities that closely match
the parameters of your search so you can
imagine if you're searching for John
Smith you might have quite a number of
John Smith's to go through and using
your control key select the ones that
you're with high certainty or your
patient the system will then provide a
report back an HTML format that looks
like this you can choose to export to a
PDF in print you can also choose to map
the results the system will provide a
map showing locations of patient
residents providers and dispensers and
of course the report shows the date
prescribed the date filled the drug name
and quantity as well as prescriber and
dispenser contact information
delegate management on the system is
also an easy process and I want to
remind you that delegates are available
for prescribers right prescribers would
be master counts on the systems and
delegates would be ancillary staff they
can delegate authority for patient query
to how does a provider do that
by accessing the system going to user
management and under delegate accounts
as you can see on the screen the
prescriber can then select from the
alphabetical list of delegates all of
the delegates they wish to be attached
to a prescriber can have many delegates
a delegate can be associated with many
prescribers it is incumbent upon the
delegate then to ensure that they're
appropriately pulling patient reports
for the appropriate prescriber for the
patient lastly we have a number of
resources available on directly from
within the PMP links to useful resources
at Samsa here at the Department of
Health to the a.m. DG that's the agency
medical directors group as well as the
CDC prescribing guidelines that
concludes my presentation thank you Gary
for that informative presentation we
will now start the Q&A portion of the
webinar and we'll address some of the
most commonly asked questions by our
viewers if you have any questions you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question drop-down box
located on the far left of your
presentation window type your question
into the box that appears on your screen
and put the send button our speaker will
respond to your questions via email
let's get started first question is how
did the changes made by House bill 27:30
improve access to the prescription
monitoring program in Washington
right so 27:30 provided access provided
the authority for a facility operating
EHR system to access the PMP and submit
and receive back a patient query report
what this did is by putting this acts
putting this authority in the hands of
the facility it says that providers in
that facility that would have access to
that PMP information through the EHR
system no longer have to necessarily
register for or maintain an active PMP
account it really reduces the overhead
for the providers the providers are able
to log in to their EHR system which
contains all manner of HIPAA compliant
information in the first place and while
they're within their workflow for the
patient the EHR system can make that
query and pull back that PMP information
for the provider so the provider has to
perform no additional actions to have
access to the information
when will Washington prescription
monitoring program users be able to
access PMP data from other states that's
a great question and something that
we're currently working on right now
we've just recently executed a
Memorandum of Understanding with one of
the national hubs that we hope to be
connected to our vendor tells us we'll
be connected to at the beginning of
December 2018 this will allow us to
exchange data with a whole lot of states
sadly it doesn't take into account the
there are two neighboring states Idaho
and Oregon are not active at this time
on this hub they're active on another
another national hub and wouldn't you
know what this is a situation where the
two hubs don't talk well to each other
so as we become active in December we're
not going to be able to we're not going
to be able to exchange be able to
exchange data with our closest papers we
really want to we're still pursuing
pursuing a connection with that second
hub we hope to iron out some issues that
our legal department has had with the
agreement to join that second hub we
hope to move forward and create that
connection but for the time being come
December we should be active on the
X check hub we should be able to
exchange data with a great number of
states and we're really excited that
we're seeing more and more states access
or join that rx check hub as well thank
you looks like we have time for one more
question
patient prescription history on the
prescription monitoring program isn't
always accurate how can be improved
certainly and again a great question
you're right prescription history isn't
always accurate on the PMP and it's
important to keep in mind where we're
getting that information from that
information is reported directly from
dispensers right those are the those are
the pharmacies that are filling and
providing the prescriptions not always
to the hand of the patient in many cases
these patients are in pain and they
don't present at the pharmacy so the
ability to check that check an ID for
legal format a name doesn't go real far
at the pharmacy many times that
information is coming directly from the
prescribers office where that
prescription has been written and this
might be the only place where there's a
veil ability an opportunity to interface
with patient and check ID for the legal
format of the name remember when writing
a prescription that information is going
to be handed off to the pharmacy and
that's the information that it's going
to be reported the PMP it is imperative
that it be accurate that it be the legal
format of the name a good and valid
address when you receive information
back from the PMP that is incorrect or
incomplete we do have a process of
reporting that back to the PMP where we
can followup with the pharmacies to
ensure that the information is corrected
on the PMP you can find a path to that
process on our web page do hy govt slash
PMP thank you I would like to once again
thank Jared Garrity for his presentation
I would also like to thank lab roots for
making today's educational webcast
possible before we go I want to let
everyone know that today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through February 15 2019 you'll receive
an email from lab roots letting you know
when this webcast will be available for
replay
please share that announcement with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
event that is all for now thank you for
joining us we hope to see you again soon
bye